the raiders are hoping to have nearly
everyone back in uniform in time to play
the chiefs on sunday night
but as john treach tells us the most
difficult game of all
is wait and see right john that's right
the raiders are wearing their mask and
keeping their distance but
still holding their breath and hoping
covet is the creep that stays away
the good news for the raiders only
cleland farrell has tested positive the
bad news
covet isn't punctual doesn't share its
infection schedule on icloud so we wait
this week the raiders contract tracers
were buzzing after cleveland farrell
tested positive for covet 19 without
symptoms three defensive backs and five
defensive linemen were held out of
practice due to
be in contact with pearl all week and
all the raiders say
the players will be ready for action if
the tests keep coming back
negative that's just the infectious
disease defense as for the chief's
defense
they are hungry to give derek carr
problems john gruden discusses
his heavy load of responsibility and
reasons for losing sleep
no i don't have any update
wait and see what happens but uh we're
just hoping everybody remains healthy
and
can get back as soon as possible well
the whole chief defense is unpred
unpredictable they don't even play a
straight defense on the goal line
so they uh they do a lot of things they
have a lot of mystery coverages and
mystery blitzes and they're
they're hard to prepare for a guy like
matthew
he thrives in that kind of a defense so
we'll have our hands full we know that
feels nice to talk about football john
gruden was speaking about tyrion matthew
the kansas city safety goes by the
nickname honey badger
a honey badger eats scorpions and snakes
you can understand how that would cause
concern
kirsten remember that video on youtube
or the honey badger thanks john